[Musica]
Salve a tutti ciao a tutti Ciao ciao a
tutti
oggi vi parlerò di una promessa d'amore
non mantenuta La promessa d'amore tra i
mass media e le lingue minoritarie
punta tanto tempo No Eh sì sì ma non e
questo è un problema è un problema che
mi sono posto un sacco di volte e per
quello che poi faccio questo mestiere
Stefano Zecchi diceva che
l'uomo ciò che guarda e questo è vero
cioè i mass media la televisione da
quando è nata
è sempre stata lo specchio della cultura
di massa e dobbiamo analizzarlo questo
fatto e questo è tanto più vero quando
si parla delle minoranze linguistiche
dobbiamo chiederci perché non si sia mai
stato un passo in più e dobbiamo
chiedercelo soprattutto
immaginando cosa vuole la gente cosa
vuole la gente no cosa cosa cosa che
vuole questa Massa Questo popolo noi che
ci occupiamo di editoria ce lo chiediamo
tutti i giorni che cosa vuole la gente
soprattutto in questo periodo I
cambiamenti sono repentini e
l'illuminori sono escluse nella società
dai processi principali esattamente come
nei media che sono lo specchio Fedele di
ciò che non succede nella società
la lingua sarda è in TV quanto basta
esattamente come la lingua sarda è nella
società quanto basta quanto la vogliamo
ci sbattiamo un sacco di volte per dire
quanto sarebbe bello all'impastare la
società Poi però non c'è e non è che ci
stiamo sbattendo a terra per dire no ma
ci doveva essere no ormai è così la
prendiamo un po' per quello che che
succede Ci sono diversi fattori su cui
riflettuto del Perché questo rapporto è
così complicato Ci rifletto ormai da
tanto in tantissimo tempo cioè il mio
lavoro come editore televisivo il mio
lavoro come conduttore televisivo e
imperniato principalmente su questi su
questi aspetti ci sono tre fattori
principali su cui riflettuto perché in
questo momento di grande di grandi
cambiamenti non siamo passati ci pensate
adesso giusto per avere una parentesi
siamo passati nell'arco di 15 anni
dall'analogico cioè dai canali dallo 0
al 9 siamo passati a centinaia di canali
a London queste top TV alla vod video On
Demand a Netflix Amazon Prime eccetera
ma in pochissimo tempo dopo aver visto
la televisione per 40 anni sempre
identica e allora ci sono questi tre
aspetti su cui su cui ho ragionato Uno è
il rapporto con la pubblica
amministrazione no con i finanziamenti
in generale
l'altro aspetto è legato ai modelli di
business Come funzionano i modelli di
business nel mondo dell'editoria E
l'ultimo è la capacità e la resilienza
di chi si occupa di media di adeguarsi
al progetto tecnologici che sono in atto
che sono appunto velocissimi Allora per
quanto riguarda la parte dei
finanziamenti pubblici saranno
brevissimo
allora è un fatto incredibile Io sono
convinto di una cosa leggi obsolete
generano il fallimento delle imprese
Questo è un dato di fatto Assoluto Per
cui se è vero che io sono una tv locale
e sono l'ultimo baluardo per la difesa
della mia lingua Io molto spesso sono
costretto a non evolvermi per star
dietro le leggi che mi finanziano la
legge arretrata e io non mi evolvo
quindi sono costretto l'immobilismo
perché se mi evolvo Poi faccio una cosa
che non è iscritta nella legge e quindi
chi me la finanzia nessuno Allora non la
faccio lascio l'antenna esattamente come
vent'anni fa perché la legge mi finanzia
l'antenna non mi finanzia la rete non mi
finanzia la fibra Non mi finanzia roba
nuova tecnologia innovative per cui
Bisognerebbe lavorare Un po' per
accelerare questo cambio normativo Poi
ci sono i modelli di business le
televisioni
sono nate con la pubblicità tabellare
ogni 12 minuti poi c'è la pubblicità
pubblicità
con un rapporto abbastanza strano con le
imprese che investono su questi su
queste trasmissioni cioè c'è la
trasmissione c'è l'investitore la
pubblicità in rotazione Ma che rapporto
c'è tra territorio impresa popolazione
cittadini e quello che va in onda boh
dipende il grande mainstream se ne
sbatte abbastanza di quello che c'è
sotto le TV locali potrebbero fare
qualcosa di più e allora dovrebbero
cambiare loro modello di business cioè
iniziare a lavorare con le aziende del
territorio con i cittadini per creare
delle opportunità che ci consentono in
questa nuova fase
dei media un'interazione è una
condivisione tale che ci consente di
portare le istanze i bisogni delle
persone dentro il mass media forse
questo agevolerebbe anche le minoranze
linguistiche Non lo so può essere
ultima cosa l'allattamento ai processi
tecnologici allora
È ovvio che se io sono
una grande mejor europea e per me è
facile Io guido la tecnologia Cambia
Cambia insieme a me Ma se io sono una
piccola TV che vende la pubblicità a un
euro al secondo Ma dov'è che me la
cambio sta tecnologia Com'è che posso
stare dietro a questa tecnologia
Praticamente impossibile e poi in più se
sono uno che si occupa in minoranza
linguistica mi finanziano o difficoltà a
vendere la pubblicità e vivo in questa
bolla che è esclusa dall'economia del
mio territorio mi muovo con questo
finanziamento che mi tiene rinchiuso
sono incapaci di relazionarmi con il
mondo circostante e quindi non mi evolvo
cioè Sono destinato all'immobilità
quindi alla morte dal punto di vista
imprenditoriale è un'equazione presto
fatta allora Voi direte Ma che cosa ci
vuoi dire per cos qual è la soluzione
non lo so se c'è una soluzione io però
vi dico qual è la mia visione
e ho da quando ho iniziato a fare questo
lavoro
Ho pensato che non potevo più usare le
parole che erano state usate prima per
parlare di quello che che avrei voluto
fare e ho pensato che se devo pensare le
minoranze linguistiche non devo più
pensare solo a me stesso non devo
pensarmi Intanto come minoranza devo
pensarmi come una cultura del mondo che
fa parte di un mondo globale molto più
ampio è una civiltà globale molto più
ampia rispettosa
capace di capire gli altri e dentro
questa mi devo muovere in Europa ci sono
circa 80 lingue minoritarie che
convivono con le 24 lingue ufficiali
dell'Europa
80 lingue minoritaria riconosciuta dagli
Stati riconosciuti dalle norme dalle
leggi europee da Strasburgo fino alla
carta Europea delle lingue regionali in
Italia del 92 fino agli atti che stanno
tutti dentro a quel grande consesso che
l'Europa unita nella diversità
ci ragioniamo ma in un altro giorno
vengo e parliamo di unità Uniti nella
diversità Che cosa significa
Però io penso a un popolo trasversale
molto più ampio di quello sardo e questo
è il mio punto di partenza in assoluto
l'altra questione è che c'è una parola
chiave su tutto che è condivisione eya
TV che l'azienda che ho fondato qualche
anno fa è partita sempre solo da questa
parola dalla parola condivisione
condividere significa creare un mezzo di
comunicazione nuovo che parta dalle
culture che sia vicino alle imprese che
sappia dare valore alle imprese del
territorio alle culture del territorio e
restituire continuamente quello che
viene prodotto Io immagino
vettori di mass media che siano capaci
di creare anche contenuti che non solo
sono vicine ai territori alle culture
alle lingue ma che creino anche degli
standard comportamentali che siano un
esempio per le persone che veicoli in
contenuti di rispetto che adesso non ci
quali sono e questo è un grandissimo
problema Io
ho pensato sempre che le nostre culture
e le nostre lingue debbano trovare uno
spazio nei mezzi di comunicazione di
massa debbano trovarlo perché gli unici
che possono conservare le minoranze
linguistiche alle nostre culture Siamo
noi che sia che ci occupiamo insomma in
qualche modo delle della nostra cultura
a livello locale e non possiamo pensare
di essere esclusi schiacciati dai grandi
Major della in Europa
un progetto su cui stiamo lavorando da
tempo e che è il progetto qui tengo in
assoluto di più è un progetto che si
chiama My cartoon è un progetto che
nasce all'interno di un Ong europea che
è composta da circa 140 associazioni il
primo progetto il nucleo
si chiamava the dream network
erano giocato su non so se vi ricordate
il film Ghostbusters
the streams cioè incrociare i flussi
cercare di mettere insieme Le istanze di
tutti per potenziare questo flusso tutti
insieme e diventare molto più forti il
progetto che sta nascendo è un progetto
di video On Demand è il primo progetto
di video On Demand globale destinato
esclusivamente ai film parlati in lingua
minoritaria e parteciperanno case di
produzione di tutta Europa che
proveranno a mettere insieme ognuno un
soldino dentro questo grande progetto
che è un progetto principalmente di
condivisione solo di condivisione ed è
solo così che le nostre minoranze
possono sopravvivere Io sono
Assolutamente convinto della grande
responsabilità che abbiamo dell'idea che
noi che ci occupiamo di comunicazione
non possiamo non tenere presente e non
tenere conto quanto importante essere
noi stessi custodi alla nostra cultura
ognuno facendo il suo pezzettino Chi ha
la possibilità di utilizzare un mezzo di
comunicazione di massa come noi che
gestiamo canali televisivi abbiamo le
Web Tv abbiamo i giornali abbiamo
assolutamente la responsabilità di
diventare un vettore di comunicazione
per tutti per cui io quello che che
vorrei dire oggi è quello che penso sia
importante in un contesto come questo
che è un contesto vicino ai cambiamenti
della società e che per guardare avanti
per essere più vicini a noi stessi per
saper portare la nostra cultura fuori
noi di nuovo sapere da dove stiamo
partendo noi dobbiamo essere
assolutamente consapevoli
dirò una parola difficile Spero che la
traduttrice lo capisca è su liminarzu
cioè la soglia di casa nulla dobbiamo
conoscere Ecco il mio progetto il nostro
progetto il progetto su cui stiamo
lavorando ha una soglia molto solida da
cui partire è un sacco di strada davanti
che vede tante persone insieme lavorare
nel rispetto di tutti e nella
condivisione di tutti grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]